jim vive en la primera avenida y la
décimo primera calle ubicación
representada por el punto 111 en la
gráfica de bajo ok
él y su mejor amigo deciden ir a la
librería que está en la quinta avenida y
la cuarta calle lugar representado por
el punto 54 en la gráfica ellos caminan
hacia abajo por la primera avenida y
después caminan sobre la cuarta calle
cuántas calles caminan para llegar ahí
gráfica su casa y la librería en el mapa
muy bien entonces nos dicen que jim vive
en la primera avenida y décimo primera
calle que está en el punto 1 punto 11
entonces la primera entrada es avenida y
la segunda es calle déjame bajar un poco
para ver
entonces tenemos que poner esto en el 1
porque es la primera venida coma 11 sale
del origen 1 hacia la derecha y 11 hacia
arriba y luego dice que la librería está
en el punto 5 4 quinta avenida y cuarta
calle entonces tenemos que ponerlo en el
5,4 o bien podemos pensar que es la
cuarta calle y quinta avenida nada más
hay que estar bueno muy al pendiente de
que no estamos confundiendo calles con
avenidas el eje x con el eje y bueno ya
tenemos estos dos puntos y luego nos
pregunta luego nos pregunta cuántas
calles caminan para llegar ahí
bueno pues dice que van a caminar hacia
abajo por la primera avenida entonces
caminarán 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 manzanas o
bloques y luego hacia la derecha sobre
la cuarta calle 1 2 3 4 manzanas
adicionales
entonces caminan 7 más 4 manzanas 7 + 4
lo que es entonces eso sería 11 la
respuesta sería 11 bloques
muy bien